[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon.
Thank you for coming.
And thank you for the very,
very gracious introduction.
So as Meredith pointed out,
as computers and computer
algorithms reach ever more
deeply into our lives,
there is an increasing
concern that they
embody societal values, such
as privacy, and fairness,
and statistical
validity, and so on.
And my work does
strive to try to put
these goals on a firm
mathematical foundation.
And my hope today is to
give you a little bit
of the flavor of how someone
like me goes about trying
to answer a question like this.
So what is some of my thinking?
I'll give two-- if time
permits, three examples.
And I will include work that
is very much in progress
right now.
So we are going to in the
end use coins for fairness.
But my goal in talking about
them right this very minute
is to just give you a little bit
of the language of probability
in case this is foreign to
you because not everybody here
has had a probability class.
So what do we mean
by a fair coin?
Most of you would
say, well, it'll
come up heads with
probability a half.
What does that statement mean?
Implicit in it is the idea
that you have some sort
of repeatable experiment.
You can flip the
coin many times.
If you flip it 1,000
times, your belief--
your guess-- is
that if it's fair,
it should come up
about 500 heads and not
too far away from that.
So that's one view of the
definition of a fair coin.
And you might wonder
if you have a coin
can you test for fairness.
And the answer is sure.
And you have to think about why.
But you can ask me about
that later if you want.
But when we talk about
whether an algorithm is fair,
you'll also maybe be
thinking, can I actually
test for fairness?
So it's the same
kind of exercise.
So very, very briefly, we need a
sample space of our experiment.
So the sample space is simply
all the possible outcomes.
If I flip a coin
once, the sample space
is just head or tail.
That's it.
It's the pair.
Those are the two elements
in the sample space.
If I roll a single die, there
are six possible outcomes.
If I'm looking at
medicine, then I
may be concerned with how many
months will somebody survive
in a five-year follow-up study.
So the number of
answers there is 61.
It could be 0, 1, 2, 3
months, 4 months, and so on,
up to 60 months.
So notice that when we had
the die and we rolled it,
the repeatable experiment
was the multiple roles.
When it comes to number of
months survived in a follow-up
study, that's not one person
who's being tested many times.
It's many people.
So we have to
understand a little bit
about where our repetitions
are coming from.
So that's the sample
space of an experiment.
Oh, and there are also
uncountably infinite sets.
If you're used to thinking
about a draw from a Gaussian
distribution, that would be
an uncountably infinite set.
We won't need that today.
Now, not all outcomes have
the same probabilities.
If I flipped a fair
coin, of course,
it would be 50/50-- the
same probability-- the same
with a die-- one in six.
But suppose I flip two coins.
So the number of heads in
the two flips of a fair coin
is going to be 0, 1, or 2.
But they don't all have
the same probability.
And the best way
to think about this
is to think about
flipping two fair coins.
We'll call one of them the
green coin and one of them
the blue coin.
And they can be flipped
in either order.
So there's a 50/50 chance
of 0 or 1 on the green coin.
And then independently there's
a 50/50 chance of 0 or 1
on the blue coin.
So each of the paths
through this diagram
has probability one fourth.
But two of those paths
result in one head.
So it's twice as
likely that we'll
see one head than that
we'll see zero heads.
That seems so obvious to us.
But this device of
thinking about the blue
and the green coin--
this wasn't even
known to Leibniz,
who developed calculus.
So a few hundred years ago--
350 years ago or so-- people
didn't understand this so well.
Now it's absolutely
bread and butter.
We'll need the notion of a
probability distribution, which
is simply a list for each
possible outcome of how
probable it is.
So these are numbers between
0 and 1 that sum to 1.
And that's the basic tutorial.
Notice that sometimes
we really have
no way of knowing which
outcome is the case.
And that doesn't mean that
they're equally likely.
So for example, we
might talk about what's
our belief about the probability
of intelligent life on Mars.
Either there is intelligent
life on Mars or there isn't.
Just because we don't
know which is which
doesn't mean that
they're equally likely.
Given all of the other
things we know about life,
they will not have
equal likelihood.
And the last notion we'll need
is conditional probability.
So I could talk about what's
the probability of rain.
Well, already you should
say, what do you mean,
what's the probability of rain?
What's my sample space
am I talking about--
days in the year in Cambridge?
Am I talking about days
in the year in California?
Am I talking about days in
Cambridge Union, California?
So let's say
Cambridge in October--
what's the probability of rain
on a random day in Cambridge
in October?
And what's the probability
of rain given that we
observe that it's cloudy.
So conditional probability talks
about how we update our beliefs
in the light of evidence.
And this is
absolutely fundamental
to the scientific method.
There are mathematical
ways of doing it.
But you should
just know that this
is what conditional
probability will do for us.
OK, so now you're
armed with the language
that you'll need to understand
at least the definition
of differential privacy.
Here's for a moment going to
be my computational model.
I have a data analyst who
interacts with a database
in a very abstract way.
She asks a question like--
what happened to Q1--
she asks a question
like, what is
the fraction of
people in the data
set that are over six feet tall?
And she gets an answer.
The fraction is 40%.
And then based on that, she
might choose a new question.
How many people like muffin tops
and gets an approximate answer
to that or gets
an answer to that.
So that's our model of a
data analyst interacting
with the database.
The question could be something
very, very complicated.
It could be a multi-part study.
It could be a
computer algorithm.
It doesn't matter.
We're just going to abstract
it away-- question, answer--
question, answer-- first
heart study on the data
set-- second heart
study on the data set,
which is informed by the
outcomes of the first heart
study, and so on.
OK, so this is a
very general model.
It's used in some sense--
you can imagine in the
census an epidemic detection
based on over-the-counter
drug purchases.
You might want to analyze
loan application data
for evidence of discrimination.
So there can be all sorts
of rich and juicy things
in this data set.
And we want to do these things
while preserving privacy.
Now, this is a problem
that's quite old.
And very specifically
we can find some results
on these sorts of
things from 1965.
And we'll talk about that later.
Now, as Meredith
mentioned, many people
think about de-identifying data.
So the dream in
de-identified data
is you start with a database
and some algorithm, M,
chomps on the
database for a while,
stripping out certain things,
and averaging and aggregating
others, and produces a
de-identified data set.
That's the hope.
And in fact, once that
happens, we don't even
need the original database.
The algorithm can go away.
And the analyst can
knock herself out
by looking at the
de-identified data set.
And the problem with this
approach is that a number
of studies have shown that
de-identified data isn't.
Either it isn't de-identified,
or it is no longer data.
So it's just--
[LAUGHTER]
So you might say,
well, why don't we
just restrict ourselves
to statistical queries?
Now, this is really intuitive.
A statistic is a quantity
computed from a sample.
The reason statistics
works as a field
is it really doesn't care
whom you have sampled.
It just cares that
you've sort of
sampled enough
people with enough
of the right distribution.
So that seems really
privacy preserving.
And yet there are problems.
So a simple example would
be a differencing attack.
Suppose we ask the
following question.
How many living
physics Nobel laureates
floss their teeth regularly?
We get the exact answer to this.
And then we ask the
question, how many
male, living, physics Nobel
laureates floss regularly?
So both of these are
pretty large sets.
There are a quite a number of
male, living, physics Nobel
laureates.
But there's only one female,
living, physics Nobel
laureate--
Donna Strickland--
as of October 2.
And so if you took one
answer and subtracted it
from the other, you would
learn whether or not
Donna Strickland flosses
regularly, which of course,
is a very personal
piece of information.
So this is a simple example.
It's a simple attack.
But one thing you
should worry about--
one thing we've learned
from cryptography
is if anybody finds a way
of breaking something,
there are probably a ton of
other ways of breaking that
and simple variations of it, and
complicated variations of it.
Like, it's always the
tip of the iceberg.
And indeed, what we
call the fundamental law
of information recovery--
I missed the citation here--
the first version was due to
Dinur and Nissim in 2003--
essentially says that
overly accurate estimates
of too many statistics
completely destroys privacy.
And the definition
of overly accurate
is tied to the
definition of too many.
So if we're going
to break privacy
and we can ask lots
and lots, then we
can make them pretty
inaccurate and still
manage to break privacy.
If we're going to just be
able to ask a few questions,
then to prove this theorem,
you need pretty tight accuracy.
So those two are connected.
OK, so here we are at Radcliffe.
This is a picture of
Cecilia Payne-Gaposchkin.
So maybe the astronomers
know who she is.
She is the first woman to
obtain a PhD in astronomy
and the first person to obtain
a PhD in astronomy at Harvard.
She was responsible for
estimating the great abundance
of hydrogen in
stars and realizing
that the stars have a
very different composition
from the Earth.
OK, so here is Cecilia Payne.
She's in the data set.
And the analyst is
talking to the data set.
And the question is, what does
privacy mean for Dr. Payne?
So what are the
guarantees or the promises
that we'd like to make to her?
The one possibility would be
to say the analyst interacting
with the database can't learn
anything new about Cecilia
Payne.
And this is in fact the
heart of the desideratum that
was articulated by
the statistician
Tordelinius in 1977 when the
statistics community was trying
to get its hands on what is
a statistical database-- what
does it mean that it's
statistical and not
about individuals.
So the problem
with that is if we
can't learn anything new about
the people in the database,
what is the point?
So suppose that
I'm from Mars and I
believe that all humans
have two left feet.
And they interact with
the statistical database.
And I learn that the
vast majority of humans
have one left foot
and one right foot.
So I used to believe that
Dr. Payne had two left feet.
Erroneously, I believed this.
And then I interacted
with the database.
And now my beliefs
about her have changed.
I've learned something
new about her.
Have I compromised
her privacy or not?
Well, suppose she had
not been in the data set.
Suppose she had opted out.
And she'd been replaced in
the data set by Henrietta Swan
Leavitt, another
Harvard astronomer, who
observed a certain mathematical
relationship between the period
of variable stars and
their peak brightnesses.
And this relationship
turned out to be
very valuable for estimating
distances across space.
So presumably, because this
is a statistical database,
we would learn the
same things if Payne
had been replaced by Leavitt.
All we needed was
enough people to learn
that the vast majority of people
have one left foot and one
right foot.
So ideally, we'd
learn the same things
if Payne is replaced by
another random member
of the population.
And that's what differential
privacy captures.
It says in English that
the outcome of any analysis
is essentially equally
likely, independent of
whether any individual
joins or refrains
from joining the data set.
In other words, the probability
distribution on outcomes
is very robust to small
changes in the data set.
Payne goes away.
Leavitt joins.
Payne's replaced by Leavitt.
Annie Jump Cannon joins.
So you've seen some
of these things--
these terms.
The likelihood here-- what's
our repeatable experiment?
Our algorithms are
going to flip coins.
They're going to
introduce randomness.
And when we talk about
measuring likelihood,
we mean with the
database fixed--
likelihood as we vary the
coins of the algorithm.
So you could run it many
times with different coins.
And you'd get probability
distribution and outcomes.
And essentially,
equally likely says
simply that similar
databases should give rise
to similar probability
distributions on outputs.
And that's basically
the definition.
So what it means is if a bad
event from my perspective
is very unlikely when
I'm not in the data set,
it's going to be
very unlikely even
if I am because the probability
distribution on the outputs
will not change much, whether
I'm in there or not in there.
So if one is analyzing
power consumption
data and a bad outcome for me
is that the police come and bust
me for maybe use of
grow lights, well,
if that's very unlikely to
happen if my data are not
included, then it will
be unlikely to happen
if they are included.
The next example has to do
with genome wide association
studies.
I'm going to skip it now.
But ask me about both of these
examples during the questions
if you wish.
So what differential
privacy does
is it allows us to
separate harms that
can happen to us based on
the teachings of the database
from harms that happen to us
as a result of our choosing
to participate in the database.
So let's think about a medical
data set where we are analyzing
the effects of smoking.
And we learn by
analyzing this data set
that smoking causes cancer.
From the perspective of
a smoker in the data set,
let's say, in some
sense, I mean, it's
really good news because the
smoker then learns to quit.
But for a moment, let's say that
this is bad news for the smoker
because it means her insurance
premiums are going to rise.
So what the differential
privacy ensures
is that those same
teachings would
be learned independent of
whether she participated
or not.
Now, of course, the whole point
of a medical database for study
is to learn things like
smoking causes cancer precisely
so that people
learn not to smoke
or that they should enter a
smoking cessation program.
So the hope was that by having
very strong privacy protection
that makes things
essentially the same
in terms of their
privacy loss risk,
whether you are
participating or not,
that you would feel
safe to participate.
So it's a strong
definition of privacy.
And you might wonder, why
is anything possible at all?
How can you possibly get
any utility whatsoever
when you have such a
strong privacy guarantee?
And one thing that we've
learned from machine learning--
from that whole field of
AI and machine learning--
is that stability to small
changes in the data set
allows you to
properly generalize,
which means to port the
things that you have
learned by analyzing
your data set
to the population as a whole.
That's the whole point
of machine learning.
And it's also the whole point
of statistical learning.
And so stability is both
necessary and sufficient
for that.
So stability or
differential privacy
will preserve Payne's
privacy and protect
against over-fitting
of the data.
So in some very real
sense, privacy and utility
are actually aligned,
as opposed to being
in conflict with each other.
So here's a simple example.
It's not quite in the
model that we discussed.
But it's just a simple example
that actually dates back
to 1965.
But we're going to analyze
it in modern terms.
So it was developed by Warner
in order to question people--
survey people-- about
embarrassing or even illegal
behaviors.
It's going to give
plausible deniability.
So the question is, did
you floss last night?
So what I'm interested
in is the fraction
of people in the room
who flossed last night.
And we could carry out this
study in a privacy preserving
way as follows.
I would give you the
following instructions.
And I would tell you to carry
them out very privately.
OK.
So flip a fair coin.
If that coin is
heads, you're going
to answer completely
randomly having
nothing to do with the truth.
You flip again.
And you respond yes if
your second coin came up
heads and no otherwise.
But if the outcome of
the first coin was tails,
you're going to answer honestly.
So you can see that
whether the truth is yes,
you flossed, or no, you
didn't, in both cases,
you might end up saying yes.
And in both cases, you
might end up saying no.
So this is where the plausible
deniability comes from.
And the privacy analysis
is straightforward.
The probability
that you say yes,
given that the truth is yes--
we're interested in this ratio--
divided by the probability
that you say yes,
given that the truth is no.
That's going to be 3.
If the truth is yes, you say
yes if the first coin is tails--
probability in half.
Or the first coin is
heads, and the second coin
is heads--
probability a quarter.
Total probability is 3/4.
If the truth is
no, you'll say yes
only if the first
and second coins
are heads, which
as we saw earlier,
has probability, a fourth.
So the ratio between them is 3--
same deal for outputting no.
So it turns out
it's very, very easy
to reverse engineer
the noise that we've
added by all of
this coin flipping
and get quite nice
approximations
to the true fraction of
people in the room who've
flossed last night.
And if I want to have better
privacy protection, what I'll
do is I'll flip a coin that
has a very small probability
of tails, so you're
very unlikely to have
to answer honestly.
Most of the time
most of the people
will end up answering randomly.
So you have to recalculate
the privacy analysis.
But you can force that
ratio to be very close to 1
by answering honestly with
much smaller probability.
So let's go back.
Remember that
conditional probability
let us say how we're going to
update our beliefs in light
of the evidence.
So now suppose the evidence
is Meredith has flipped
and she says no.
Well, it's not
very good evidence
because maybe if I had
chosen my parameters nicely,
I'd be essentially
equally likely to see
that no whether she
flossed last night or not.
So in this updating
of the beliefs,
very little is changing.
There's very little information.
OK, and for the mathematicians
here, this is the definition.
Adjacent data sets are
data sets that differ
in the data of just one person.
And we say that our algorithm
gives us epsilon differential
privacy if this equation
holds where the probability
spaces over the randomness
introduced by our algorithms.
And this parameter
epsilon here is
a measure of the
privacy loss, or it's
an upper bound on
the privacy loss.
OK, couple properties of this--
it's future proof.
So let's say that we run
a differentially private
algorithm from this.
Even if we knew which were the
two possible adjacent data sets
and all we care
about is learning
about the data of the
one person who is not
in both of those
databases, no matter
what we learn in
the future won't
erode the privacy guarantee
that we got at the beginning.
So you can't leverage
this to make things worse
in post-processing.
Also, we understand how
differentially private
algorithms compose.
That's the formal
term for saying,
what is the cumulative
privacy loss as we
run through one differentially
private algorithm
after another with their
own privacy parameters?
So we understand
how it composes.
It composes gracefully,
automatically, and adaptively.
So the fact that the
adversary or the analyst
get to ask her questions
based on previous questions
and answers doesn't
harm anything.
There may or may not
be time to tell you
about the importance of
that observation later.
As a result, because we
understand composition,
we can now program in a
differentially private way.
What that means is we can
create little differentially
private building blocks-- little
basic, you know, primitives.
And now we can put them together
in creative and interesting
ways to carry out
complicated computations
while trying to minimize
the cumulative privacy loss.
And that is really what sets
differential privacy aside
from all other techniques
because in some sense
potentially the sky's the limit.
So now we get to fairness.
The concern in algorithmic
fairness is the following.
We have a population
which is diverse.
There are ethnic divisions,
religious divisions,
geographic, medical, gender,
class, sexual preference,
and all sorts of things.
And what we want is we
want to have algorithms
that are somehow fair.
Now, we will spend
some time thinking
about how to define fair.
But you all probably
have some sort
of intuitive notion
of what fair means.
Now, how would you be sure
that your algorithm is not,
say, discriminating
on the basis of sex?
So one possibility might be to
hide the sensitive information
from the algorithm-- just not
have that information as one
of the inputs--
not have it in the description
of [? Cynthia, ?] for example.
And that doesn't work.
And the reason is
sensitive attributes
can be sort of holographically
embedded in our data.
And a classic example of
this is the correlation
between race and zip
code, which comes up
in redlining, which was an
illegal practice in the housing
loan industry where
zip codes were
being used as proxies for race.
And I strongly recommend
reading Rothstein's book,
The Color of Law, talking about
the history of this and showing
that this was du jour--
not just de facto--
and that it was a result of
government actions, which has
a lot of implications legally.
OK.
Now, another problem
with the idea
of hiding the
sensitive information
is that algorithms that
have more information
can do a better job.
So suppose you have
a minority group
in which hearing voices is a
common religious experience.
But in the majority
community, hearing voices
is diagnostic of schizophrenia.
So given somebody
is hearing voices,
one of the first things
you'd want to know is, hey,
is this a normal
religious experience
for you or in your community
before jumping to conclusions.
So a culturally aware algorithm
will be more accurate.
Now, I'm going to
introduce my majority
and my minority groups
for the rest of the talk.
So the population
is divided according
to what herbs we like to
use for flavoring our food.
And the majority
likes to use thyme.
And the minority
likes to use sage.
And they'll be referred to
as T and S, respectively.
Many algorithms in
machine learning,
particularly supervised
are given historical
examples to learn from.
So we will have
data and outcomes--
for example, loan applications
and whether or not
the loan was granted.
And the goal of the
algorithm is to figure out
to the best of its
ability how to imitate
what has been done in the past.
So you can see that if
there were biased decisions
in the past, then this bias will
be just imbibed in the mother's
milk of training data.
And so you have to do something
to watch out for this.
And this brings up a
really serious problem,
which is in general, when
we think about these things,
we don't have a source
of ground truth.
We know what was
done in the past
or how things would have
been done in the past.
But we don't know what should
be done-- what's the right thing
to be done-- what's the
accurate thing to be done.
So I'm going to
focus specifically
on classification algorithms.
So this is from
the Sistine Chapel.
This is God deciding
who's going to heaven
and who's going to hell.
It's a binary classification.
[LAUGHTER]
But there's also risk
assessment scoring--
a scoring notion.
So in this case, the goal is
to classify arrested children
according to some
measure of risk.
Children are
scored, for example,
based on their current offense--
their previous offenses.
They'll have points
deducted if there
are mitigating circumstances.
But they end up
with a score that
is supposed to say something
about how likely they are to--
I don't know exactly
what the risk
is that's being measured here.
So sometimes these
scores are translated
into binary decisions.
In this case, the
binary decision
is whether you should detain
the child or release the child.
So you can have
scoring algorithms.
They can be turned into binary
classification algorithms.
So now let's try some
definitions of fairness
with these motivating
scenarios in mind.
Broadly speaking, there are two
general kinds of definitions.
One is group fairness.
And one is individual fairness.
So group fairness is
the first thing that
will come to everybody's mind.
So we'll give some examples
or at least one example.
These are statistical
properties about the treatment
of the groups as a whole.
So one of them, which I called
here a statistical parity--
it's also called demographic
parity in the literature--
says that, say, in the binary
classification setting,
the demographics of the people
with a positive classification
should be the same as
the demographics of those
in the general population.
If a third of your
population is sage eating,
then a third of the people
that you give loans to
should be sage eating.
And similarly, a third of
the people that you deny
should be sage eating.
That's demographic parity, a
very normal, natural notion.
For the most part, it's like
a red flag in the breach.
So if you find that
the sage eaters are
being disproportionately
turned down for loans,
then maybe it's an
indication of bias.
And you might want to
investigate further.
But it's not necessarily
so meaningful
when we actually have
demographic parity.
So one example would
be in an advertising
setting in which let's say
you're advertising a spa.
And you really don't want
the sage eaters at your spa.
But you have to advertise
to them in proportion
for the population.
So what you do is you advertise
to the sage eaters who
can't afford your spa.
And you advertise to the
thyme eaters who can.
And now you preserve
your discrimination
while appearing to have complied
with the demographic parity.
So another issue that
arises is sometimes
called fairness gerrymandering.
So let's say that
the algorithm has
demographic parity with respect
to sage eaters and thyme
eaters.
And maybe it has demographic
parity with respect
to coffee drinkers
and tea drinkers.
But it's really not treating
the tea drinking, sage eaters
very well.
So they're disproportionately
discriminated against.
And that's a problem.
That says, oh, my gosh, I
might have had 10 attributes,
and now I have 2 to the 10.
I have 1,024 things
I have to look at.
So another issue I'm not
going to go through--
other definitions-- other
notions of group fairness.
But another issue is that
group fairness criteria,
each of which are
very desirable,
may be mutually incompatible.
And you can't have
all of them at once.
And this is at the heart
of the controversies
surrounding recidivism
prediction algorithms--
and a particular controversy
surrounding recidivism
prediction algorithms.
And again, I invite
you to ask about that.
OK, well, a different notion
is individual fairness.
And the intuition behind
individual fairness
is that people who are similar
with respect to a given
classification task should
be classified similarly.
So in order to make any
sense of this whatsoever,
we have to understand for
a given classification
task what does it mean to
be similar or dissimilar?
How do we figure out how
dissimilar people are?
So credit scores in some sense
are an effort to do this.
If people are very
different in credit scores,
then we feel that they are
very different when it comes
to their eligibility for loans.
If they're very
similar, then we think
they should be
treated similarly.
So we need the right
notion of dissimilarity.
And we need to get
our hands on it.
And another issue
here is that you
might think that, oh,
gee, there are going
to be these boundary cases.
It's like if you've
graded students,
you've got students
who are very similar.
And one of them is going to
get an A. And the other one's
going to get a B. And what are
you going to do about this?
So imagine that credit
scores, for example,
are sort of smeared neatly
across the population.
So there aren't big
gaps in credit scores.
So you'll have a pair of
people, U and V, one of whom
is going to get a loan approved
and the other one will not.
And yet they're
really, really close
to each other in
their credit scores.
So problem-- you have to
draw the line somewhere.
But not if you were thinking
about flipping coins.
What you can do instead
is you can map individuals
to probability distributions
over the outcomes.
And you can require that similar
people have similar probability
distributions over
outcomes, just
as we did with
differential privacy
when we required that
similar databases would
have similar probabilities--
distributions.
So of course, a
big problem still
is where do you get
your metric from?
But also, what should
the metric capture?
So let's say that we
have a Nice News company.
An individual, x, is going to
apply for a job at Nice News.
x will interact with
the environment there.
There's randomness
in the environment.
There's randomness in x's life.
But there's a
well-defined probability.
You can't find it, but there's a
well-defined probability that x
will succeed in the
job where, let's say,
success is something
very specific--
stays in the job two years--
has at least one promotion
during that time.
So what we would want is that
if the probability of success
for x and y are very
similar to each other,
then they should have similar
probabilities of being
classified as higher
by an algorithm--
makes perfect sense.
Similar people should
be treated similarly.
But what if the environment
is hostile to sage eaters?
So this is not Nice News.
This is Nasty News.
And now what should the
metric be measuring?
Should it be measuring talent?
Should it be measuring their
probability of success the way
it was before?
They are not the
same thing anymore.
You need some judgment here.
So this is a very poorly
explored area so far,
but that I hope to
change this semester.
So we've seen sort of
group fairness notions
and individual fairness notions.
There's now work on
trying to bridge the gap.
And one of the
simplest approaches--
it's not going to seem super
simple, but I promise you
this is the simplest
version of it--
is something called
multi-accuracy,
proposed by Hebert-Johnson,
Kim, Reingold, and Roth.
So imagine a world
where each individual
is holding a secret coin.
The coin is biased.
It captures this
individual's probability of,
let's say, defaulting on a loan.
So some people will have very
low probabilities of defaulting
because they're very organized.
And they're very secure
financially in many ways--
big families, outreach
network, and so on.
Other people are in much
more precarious situations.
So that's captured by the
different biases of the coin.
Bias is not an evil term here.
I just mean it's
not a fair coin--
not a 50/50 coin.
Now, our algorithm
is going to try
to learn to estimate the
bias of each person's coin.
But it doesn't actually
get to see coins.
It just gets to see the
results of various coin flips.
This is the historical data.
So this is learning
how to predict risk
based on training data.
So I've seen many, many
people who look a lot like you
in terms of financials.
And those people-- you
know, about a third of them
default on the
loans, so I'm going
to guess that your probability
of defaulting is about a third.
That's what's going on there.
That's perfectly fine.
So you could say that
a prediction algorithm
has approximately accurate
expectation for a group--
S, like the sage eaters--
if the predictions
when I average them
over the elements of S are
approximately accurate.
Well, that sounds pretty good.
But it turns out for
technical reasons,
it's not as nice as it seems.
So instead, the requirement
is strengthened.
They require a
multi-accurate expectation
for a collection of groups.
What that means is
for every group that's
listed in this
collection, it's going
to be approximately accurate--
have approximately accurate
expectation for that group.
So that tends to make
things a lot better,
although I didn't have
a chance to explain
why it was a weak notion when
I was only looking at one set.
And the nice thing about this is
that these kinds of predictors
can be constructed via
machine learning techniques
for large enough sets
in the collection.
So if our sets are
things like the sage
eaters, the thyme
eaters, the sage
eating coffee drinkers,
people who wear purple,
and so on, you're
going to get something
that's pretty nice for all of
these groups, which is great.
But which groups should you
actually be thinking about?
So this is also the question
that you would ask yourself
if somebody hands you a
predictor and a whole bunch
of data, and says, go ahead.
Audit my predictor.
And see if it's behaving well.
Here's the data.
See if it's behaving fairly.
You probably would
think, well, I'll
be sure that it's even-handed
with respect to men and women,
and sage eaters
and thyme eaters,
and coffee drinkers
and tea drinkers,
and people who wear dresses
versus people who prefer pants,
and all sorts of things, and
straight and not straight,
and so on.
So which groups?
Now, the problem that
I was really struggling
with over the summer was how do
you know that you're supposed
to look at a particular group?
So if you have a
disadvantaged group--
an oppressed group--
you can't expect
them to stand up
and say, look at us.
We're not being treated fairly.
They may have actually
taken in the message
that they are supposed
to be underachieving.
So how do you use
technology somehow
to step outside the
frame of reference
and be sure you're checking
all of the right things
or demanding all of the
right groups to be covered?
So this is where we say
complexity theory rocks.
We don't have to actually
list these groups.
We can classify them implicitly.
We can say I want to
consider all groups that
can be defined by small circuits
or little tiny programs--
well, simple
programs, let's say--
very simple programs.
Now, if you do that, all
of the machinery works.
You will almost
surely capture all
of the normal types
of discrimination
that people think about.
But you'll also have a
net for many more types.
You'll catch them
in your net as well.
So this is why I fell in
love with the multi-accuracy
and its strengthening to
what's called multi-calibration
because it gave me an answer
to this question of how
do you decide which groups
you should be looking at.
You don't have to.
And a interesting
psychology question
is how much work do
we do computationally
when we are discriminating?
Do we do a lot of
work to place someone
into the bin of
discriminate against them?
Or is it a very easy
computation in our mind?
And my conjecture is that
it's a simple computation.
But I don't know.
The flip side of this
also is if there's
a group that's
discriminated against,
but you have to compute
really hard to find them,
maybe in practice, it's just
not happening that much.
OK, so the last
couple of minutes I'll
spend on affirmative action--
group remedies.
And again, this also is
very much in progress.
So one way that we can
do affirmative action
is if we have rankings.
And there are real
life examples of this.
So in the University of
Texas and in the University
of California
system, students who
are ranked in the top 10% of
their own high school's class
are automatically
granted admission
to one of the
state universities.
So that's great.
And there's another example
of similar but more nuanced
thinking by John Roemer,
who talked about stratifying
students according to the
education level of the mother,
and within each stratum,
ranking each student
by the number of hours they
spend on homework per week,
and then taking
to the university
the top appropriately chosen
K percent from each stratum.
So you fix K so that the
number of admitted students
is the right answer.
And his point was
that a student who
comes from an uneducated
home may not even
realize it's possible to
spend 10 or 15 hours a week
on homework.
They've never maybe
seen it modeled.
Now, a different way
if you have a metric
is something like this.
And this is highly simplified.
Suppose for this
simple version of it,
we have the same number of
sage eaters and thyme eaters.
And we have a distance
for each sage eater.
We know how far they are
from each thyme eater.
The idea is that we
will pair up the sage
eaters and the thyme
eaters so that we minimize
the sum of the distances over--
for each sage eater how far it
is to its corresponding thyme
eater.
And then we will
classify the sage eater.
We first learn how to
classify the thyme eaters.
And then when we want to
classify a sage eater,
we just follow it to its
paired up thyme eater.
And we see how
they're classified.
So we do something like that.
We use earth mover distances.
And the sage eaters are
mapped to distributions
over thyme eaters.
And similar, sage eaters
are mapped similarly.
OK.
So that actually works.
But again, there's
this problem, where
does the metric come from?
So we know how to handle
multiple disjoint minority
groups.
If we have a metric, we
just do the same things
for both the multiple
different groups.
And I should point out
here that if, let's say,
a third of the thyme eaters
are given loans, then
a third of the sage eaters
will because of that 1 to 1
matching.
And that also happens in
the more rigorous version.
If we don't have a metric,
quite surprisingly,
we can build something,
which we call a fair ranking,
from any multi-accurate
predictor.
And then we can play those
ranking games that were done,
say, by the University
of California.
Right.
OK.
So the intersectional
case, though, remains open.
We don't know how to do these
affirmative action games--
games-- I mean, strategies--
if our sets of minority
groups intersect.
And of course, that's the
really interesting case
when you have someone
who is both a sage
eater and a rosemary eater.
OK, so I think I'm out of time.
And so I'll skip to the end.
And I'll be happy to
take some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]